Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Duren Hi, welcome along to this Spiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for listening and thank you, as ever, for being part of my world. I just wanted to use today's episode to really think about, well, the podcast really. We just turned six months old on the 24th of June. I'm speaking to you at the start of July as I record this. And so I thought it'd be a really nice chance to reflect and consider, you know, the episodes that have gone before and what it's been like for me to record those episodes and how they've been received, you know, some of the feedback that I've received. And, you know, you might be thinking, well, how many people listen to these episodes, Marianne. And I'm going to tell you, I'm going to give you a up to the minute as of 10 minutes ago, overview of how many people are listening
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。感谢你的收听，也一如既往地感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我今天想利用这期节目来聊聊这个播客本身。我们在6月24日刚刚满六个月。我录制这期节目时是7月初。所以我觉得这是一个很好的机会来回顾一下，思考一下之前的节目，录制这些节目的感受，以及它们收到的反馈。你可能会想，Marianne，到底有多少人在听这些节目呢？我会告诉你的，我会给你一个截至10分钟前，关于每期节目收听人数的最新概览。
to each episode. And hopefully, if you've missed any episodes, this might encourage you to listen back to them as well. That would be wonderful. Right. So as you may know, the podcast recently exceeded 9,000 downloads in the six month period. As of this very minute, we're at 9,453. So I really think and hope by the time you listen to this in a few weeks time that we will have surpassed the 10,000 download mark, which is no mean feat. form that I pay for. And they contacted me to let me know that most podcasts don't get beyond 20 episodes. So to be able to be celebrating today, the release of episode 30, it feels really lovely and it feels really good that people are really enjoying the content. So, you know, to be, you know, celebrating almost 10,000 downloads in six months for an idea that I just came up with one evening when I was cooking dinner, I just literally thought, right, I could totally do a podcast for aspiring psychologists. I'm gonna, I'm just gonna get
希望如果你错过了任何一期节目，这能鼓励你回头去听听。那将非常棒。好了，正如你可能知道的，该播客在六个月内下载量最近超过了9000次。截至此时此刻，我们达到了9453次。所以我真的认为并希望，当你几周后听到这期节目时，我们已经突破了10000次下载大关，这可不是一件容易的事。我付费使用的平台联系我，告诉我大多数播客都撑不过20期。所以今天能庆祝第30期节目的发布，感觉真的很棒，也让我感到非常欣慰，因为大家真的很喜欢这些内容。所以，为一个我某天晚上做晚饭时想到的点子，在六个月内庆祝近10000次下载，我当时真的只是想，好吧，我完全可以为有抱负的心理学家做一个播客。我打算，我打算开始
started. I'm gonna record some episodes. Um, and I'm gonna just keep going, you know, I'm gonna motivate myself. Um, I'm gonna edit them. I'm gonna think of some stuff that I would have liked to listen to when I was an aspiring psychologist and then I'm going to see what people think. So that's what I did. And yeah, it's been really lovely hearing from you how you're slotting this into your lives and into your weekly schedules. I know that one of you likes to listen while she's at the gym in between reps. I can't believe you do that. You know, in between reps, I sit and pant. So well done to you. I'm sure you know who you are. And others of you like to go running and listen. Others of you like to listen to me before you go to bed. Um, you know, you're slotting this
录制一些节目。嗯，我会坚持下去，你知道的，我会激励自己。我会剪辑它们。我会想一些我在做有抱负的心理学家时想听的内容，然后看看大家的反应。这就是我所做的。是的，听到你们分享这些内容是如何融入你们的生活和每周日程的，真的非常美好。我知道你们中有人喜欢在健身房做组间休息时听。我简直不敢相信你会这样做。你知道，在组间休息时，我只会坐着喘气。所以为你点赞。我相信你知道你是谁。还有些人喜欢在跑步时听。还有些人喜欢在睡前听我的节目。嗯，你知道，你们把这些
into your practice and really enjoying it. Um, I know someone else who listens whilst they're on the treadmill as well. So this is good stuff, you know, and it feels like a real honor and a real privilege. Um, and as you, if you are an avid listener, you will have noticed sounds and changes in my audio over time. And I'm hoping that this current one is going to be a good fit because I've rigged up my boom arm and everything and I'm sitting in a very boring room as I speak to you. My laptop seems to be a little bit noisier than ideal today, but I'm hoping this sounds all right for you. So with no further ado, let's have a look at the stats for the episodes and what each episode has been. So the trailer was launched a couple of weeks, I think, before the main launch in December, because I wanted to get the podcast all approved, which can take a few days. It
融入到你们的实践中，并且真的很享受。嗯，我还知道另一个人在跑步机上时也会听。所以这很棒，你知道，这感觉真是一种荣誉和特权。嗯，如果你是一位忠实的听众，你会注意到我的音频随着时间的推移有一些声音和变化。我希望这次的设置会很合适，因为我架好了我的悬臂支架，而且我说话时正坐在一个非常无聊的房间里。我的笔记本电脑今天似乎比平时吵一点，但我希望这对你来说听起来还可以。那么，废话少说，让我们来看看各期节目的统计数据以及每期节目的内容。预告片是在12月正式发布前几周推出的，因为我想让播客获得批准，这可能需要几天时间。它
actually took a few weeks for Apple, so that I would be ready to share it more widely, so that I would be ready to share it more widely so that as soon as it was launched, people would be able to get their hands on it. So the trailer was launched mid-December and it was just a couple of minutes. I think I probably could do with re-recording it really to make it a little bit puncture. So that might add that to my to-do list but so far the trailers had 486 downloads so thank you to each one of you who's listened to that the first ever episode which was released along with episode two and three on Christmas Eve 2021, was called Making the Most of Not That Relevant Psychology Experience. And that is the one where I talk to you about office chair Olympics and soup. But it felt like a really nice episode and people have said they found it really useful and gave them lots of ideas. That has had a whopping 719 downloads, which is really, really good.
实际上花了苹果公司几周的时间，这样我就能更广泛地分享它，这样一旦发布，人们就能立刻收听。所以预告片是在12月中旬发布的，只有几分钟长。我想我可能需要重新录制一下，让它更简洁。所以我可能会把它加到我的待办事项清单里，但到目前为止，预告片已经有486次下载了，所以感谢每一位收听过它的听众。第一期节目与第二期和第三期一起在2021年平安夜发布，题目是《充分利用那些看似不相关的心理学经验》。在那期节目里，我谈到了办公椅奥运会和汤。但那感觉是一期非常好的节目，人们说他们觉得它非常有用，给了他们很多启发。那期节目有高达719次的下载量，这真的非常非常棒。
I believe that might be our most popular episode so far. So, you know, to those 719 people, if you've not been back to listen to other episodes, why not? What did I do wrong? What were you expecting? What were you hoping for? Perhaps you didn't like the jingles, in which case maybe we're not meant to be friends. But you know, what made you stop listening? You know, I know we've all got busy lives, but what made you not click on and listen to episode two? Because could have done you know it was available that day so um if you have only listened to one um or you never even got around to to listening perhaps you subscribed and started episode one but never came back to it and now you're listening to this
我相信那可能是我们目前最受欢迎的一期节目。所以，对于那719个人，如果你没有回头去听其他节目，为什么呢？我做错了什么？你在期待什么？你在希望什么？也许你不喜欢片头曲，如果是这样的话，也许我们注定做不成朋友。但你知道，是什么让你停止收听了呢？我知道我们都很忙，但是什么让你没有点击去听第二期呢？因为你可以做到的，你知道它那天就已经发布了。所以，如果你只听过一期，或者你甚至从来没来得及听，也许你订阅了并开始了第一期，但从未回来过，而现在你正在听这期
episode which i think is 32 or 33 i got a bit lost um you, how could I encourage you to go back through to listen to them? So thank you for those of you who did listen and who went on to listen to episode two, which is making the most, making the most. I'm totally going to leave that in so that, you know know I'm not a complete control freak. Making the most of supervision and the supervisory relationship was episode two and that's had as of now 586 downloads which is great. Supervision is so key to so much of what we do and it's you know really part of our formative experiences it can feel like you know can feel really good it can feel really bad can make us think we're a good enough psychologist it can make us think we're great can make us think we're not very good and we should quit the profession so getting it right and being able to work through any difficulties is so important. And within that episode,
节目，我想这是第32或33期，我有点迷糊了。我该如何鼓励你回头去听它们呢？所以感谢那些确实听了，并继续听了第二期的听众，第二期是《充分利用督导和督导关系》。我绝对会把刚才的口误留在节目里，这样你就知道我不是一个完全的控制狂。第二期有586次下载，这很棒。督导是我们所做工作的核心，它确实是我们成长经历的一部分。它可能感觉非常好，也可能感觉非常糟糕，它可能让我们觉得自己是一个足够好的心理学家，也可能让我们觉得自己很棒，或者让我们觉得自己不够好，应该退出这个行业。所以做好督导，并能够解决任何困难是非常重要的。在那期节目中，
there was an option for being able to download my free supervision shaping tool. So do look out for that as well. Episode three was navigating life events as an aspiring psychologist and that was all sorts of things really grief um parenting um trauma i think we touched on um what else was that splitting up a relationship um all those kinds of things um and that has had 359 downloads so far. There's a bit of a theme coming on here, which I will highlight imminently. Keep listening, won't you? Episode four was self-compassion as an aspiring psychologist. And honestly, it key you absolutely need it i know it doesn't sound very exciting it doesn't sound very sexy but you need it and in order to get through and i don't know survive endure what's going ahead you need to welcome it into your life so
有一个选项可以下载我免费的督导塑造工具。所以也要留意那个。第三期是《作为有抱负的心理学家应对生活事件》，那涵盖了各种各样的事情，悲伤、育儿、创伤，我想我们还提到了分手，所有这些事情。到目前为止有359次下载。这里出现了一个主题，我很快会强调。继续听，好吗？第四期是《作为有抱负的心理学家的自我同情》。老实说，这非常关键，你绝对需要它。我知道它听起来不是很令人兴奋，也不怎么性感，但你需要它。为了度过难关，我不知道，为了生存、忍受即将到来的一切，你需要把它引入你的生活，所以
well done to the 324 people who've listened to that episode but I think that one needs to be the most popular episode really because it's so key um episode five creating opportunities for teaching training and consultation this is This is one of our most poorly listened to episodes of the original kind of set. And that's 270. But it's a really key part of the strands of being a clinical psychologist. So do listen to that one, which is episode five. Episode six, developing skills in non-invasive history taking that was a special request that was one that someone had asked me to record and that has had
为那324位收听了那期节目的听众点赞。但我认为那期节目其实应该是最受欢迎的，因为它太关键了。第五期《为教学、培训和咨询创造机会》，这是我们最初系列中收听率最低的节目之一。只有270次。但它是临床心理学家工作的重要组成部分。所以一定要听听那一期，也就是第五期。第六期《培养非侵入式病史采集技能》，这是一个特别请求，是有人要求我录制的，那期节目有
299 listens so far so that's really good let's keep that going because it's a really key skill in your developing career as a psychologist, regardless of what branch of psychology you'd like to specialize in. It's a really important skill. So do take a listen to that. seven and that will run through everything you do probably in whatever sphere of psychology you get involved with as well so do take a listen to that 319 of you have done so far episode eight so date is boundary setting for yourself and your clients and that's really important stuff such as you know turning up on time and um you know making the most of the sessions and the time and um you know being honest about any difficulties and you know setting guidelines for what's acceptable to wear during a Zoom session, you know, being naked from the waist up, not cool for me. I need you to be wearing some clothes if we're doing a Zoom session, stuff like that. And 333 of you have listened to that so far. Episode nine was the first of the
299次收听，所以这真的很棒。让我们保持下去，因为这是你作为心理学家职业发展中的一项关键技能，无论你想专攻哪个心理学分支。这是一项非常重要的技能。所以一定要听听那一期。第七期，它将贯穿你所做的一切，可能在你参与的任何心理学领域也是如此，所以一定要听听那一期，到目前为止有319人收听了。第八期是关于为你自己和你的客户设定界限，这非常重要，比如准时到达，充分利用会话和时间，诚实面对任何困难，以及设定关于Zoom会议期间着装的准则，比如，腰部以上赤裸，对我来说是不行的。如果我们进行Zoom会议，我需要你穿上衣服，诸如此类。到目前为止有333人收听了。第九期是第一期
ones I didn't record all in one go so I did um all of the first eight I did over a course of a few days and then get got them edited and scheduled um done all the snippets and done all the show notes it was it was like a super slick operation when I first started um and yeah nine was the first one that I'd done um you know when i knew that people were listening um and so that felt kind of cool you know when i did the first eight it was just me chatting to myself not knowing if anyone would ever listen um so um episode nine is yay you've got the job so now what and that kind of touches on imposter syndrome, really, and whether we feel like we're enough. And 325 of you have benefited from the wisdom within that.
我没有一次性录完的节目。我是在几天内完成了前八期，然后把它们剪辑好、排期，做了所有的片段和节目笔记。我刚开始的时候，这就像是一个超级流畅的操作。是的，第九期是我知道有人在听之后录制的第一期。所以这感觉很酷。当我做前八期时，只是我自己和自己聊天，不知道是否会有人听。所以，第九期是《耶！你得到这份工作了，现在怎么办？》，那期节目触及了冒名顶替综合症，以及我们是否觉得自己足够好。你们中有325人从其中的智慧中受益。
Episode 10 is how to optimally prepare for a psychology interview. And it won't surprise you. I think that is the most um other than the trailer so far um and that is at 640 downloads um so yeah it's a good one people have found it useful they said that it was really useful so um if you've got any kind of interview coming up um within your psychology career um be that for you know relevant psychology experience or um you know voluntary honorary experience doctoral experience um a master's i don't know anything you like give that a listen episode 11 is about understanding trauma and why it matters really and why it's so prevalent in psychology to understand that and to truly have a trauma
第10期是《如何为心理学面试做最佳准备》。这不会让你感到惊讶。我认为除了预告片之外，这是目前最受欢迎的，下载量为640次。所以是的，这是一期很好的节目，人们觉得它很有用，他们说它非常有帮助。所以，如果你在心理学职业生涯中即将面临任何面试，无论是为了相关的心理学经验，还是志愿荣誉经验、博士经验、硕士学位，我不知道，任何你喜欢的，去听听那一期。第11期是关于理解创伤以及它为什么如此重要，以及为什么在心理学中理解这一点并真正拥有一个创伤
informed service. You might listen to that episode and you'll be like, wow, she says um a lot i thought we could have an um bop challenge where people listen to it and try and count the ums and if you want to do that you know maybe we'll fling a prize in there as well let me know how many ums you can count in episode 11 of the aspiring psychologist podcast which is all about trauma 368 of you have done so far um but yeah if you want to take part in the unbop challenge listen to that one and the reason as i reflected um when i listened to it back in my kitchen i just hadn't noticed it when i edited it when i listened back to it i think it was just the really wanting to get it right. And when I spoke more recently to, to Carl, who you will meet, you'll already, already have met. I think he's episode 31. He gave me some really interesting insights into the word and
知情服务是如此普遍。你可能会听那期节目，然后你会说，哇，她说“嗯”的次数太多了。我想我们可以搞一个“嗯”挑战，人们听的时候试着数一下“嗯”的次数。如果你想这样做，你知道，也许我们会加一个奖品。让我知道你在《有抱负的心理学家》播客第11期（关于创伤的那期）里能数出多少个“嗯”。到目前为止有368人收听了。但如果你想参加“嗯”挑战，去听听那一期。我反思的原因是，当我在厨房里回听时，我在剪辑时根本没注意到。当我回听时，我想那只是因为我真的想把它做好。当我最近和Carl交谈时，你会见到他，你可能已经见过了，我想他是第31期。他给了我一些关于这个词的非常有趣的见解，以及
why we say it. So yeah, as you're listening to this, which I think is like episode 33, I'm going to say 32, I don't know, I'm not sure. Have a listen to the episode from Carl as well, as well as the Unbop episode about trauma, episode eight. Did I say how many people have downloaded that? I think so. 368. Yes, I did, didn't I? Okay. Episode 12 is all about resilience and whether it's always what it's cracked up to be in the world of psychology. 224 of you've listened to that, but it's an incredibly useful episode. And so I would urge the rest of you to also listen to that as well and because you know it's something that's spoken about a lot in psychology but in a way of kind of we just need to grin and bear it you just need to get through and not be broken and dented by the
为什么我们说它。所以，当你听这期节目时，我想这是第33期，我会说是32期，我不知道，我不确定。也去听听Carl的那期节目，以及关于创伤的“嗯”挑战那期。第八期，我说过有多少人下载了吗？我想是的，368次。是的，我说过，对吧？好的。第12期是关于韧性，以及它在心理学界是否总是像人们说的那样重要。你们中有224人听了那期，但这是一期非常有用的节目。所以我强烈建议你们其他人也去听听，因为这是心理学中经常被谈论的话题，但方式往往是我们需要咬牙坚持，你只需要熬过去，不要被这个过程弄得伤痕累累。但你知道，这在那个领域是一个小小的重新思考。这也是临床心理学家集体中人们经常谈论的话题。但我认为韧性、同情心和生活事件，还有第13期，你知道，与Ollie Matthews谈论健康和保健目标，那期有205次下载。所以我的主题是，那些真正能滋养你，而不仅仅是教你技能的节目，是目前下载量最少的。实际上，我认为这些正是你最需要的，也是对你个人和职业生涯影响最大的。所以是的，学习、学习、再学习，获取、获取、再获取的动力和欲望是有的。但我们也需要能够与自己相处，思考我们可以解决、改进或利用我们已经拥有的技能的事情。而且，知道我们已经足够好了，而不是不断地感到那种冲动去，
process but you know it's a little bit of a rethink around that area. And it's something that people talk a lot about in the clinical psychologist collective as well. But I think that the resilience and the compassion and the life events, and then also episode 13, you know, the health and wellness goals with Ollie Matthews, 2055 episodes for that 205 downloads for that one all so my theme is the ones that will actually help nourish you not necessarily just teach you skills are the least downloaded episodes so far and actually i think those are the ones that you need the most and that will make the biggest difference to you personally and professionally. So yes, there can be a drive and a desire to learn, learn, learn and take, take, take. But we also need to be able to sit with ourselves and think about the things that we might be able to, you know, work through, improve, or draw upon the skills we've already got going on for us. And, you know, knowing that we are enough, rather than constantly feeling that urge to,
你知道，去学习更多，做更多，成为更多。所以请务必听听我强调的这些节目。但这个例子，这个例子就是，一定要听韧性那期，也就是第12期。所以我们涵盖了第13期，关于健康和保健目标，以及与可爱的Olly Matthews讨论正畸厌食症和饮食失调。第14期是关于自动民族志，它是什么，我们如何了解更多，并利用它在心理学中谈论我们自己和我们自己的故事，这是叙事疗法的一个关键部分，也有助于你建立反思技能。到目前为止有216人收听了。第15期是
you know, to learn more, do more, more you know be more um so please do listen to the episodes um that i've highlighted but this case in in point this case in point would be do listen to the resilience episode which is episode 12 um so we've covered episode 13 which is health and wellness goals and also thinking about orthorexia and eating disorders with the lovely Olly Matthews. Episode 14 was autoethnography, what it is and how we can learn more about it and use it to talk about ourselves and our own story within psychology which is a really key part of narrative therapy, but also helps you to build your skills in reflection. So 216 of you have listened to that so far. Episode 15 is how
如何为演讲做最佳准备。在心理学中，能够做到这一点非常重要。这并不总是意味着像PowerPoint那样的工作。你知道，它可能只是在查房时演讲，或者谈论你的一些研究，甚至是在督导中演讲。到目前为止，那期节目有217次下载，但我们绝对需要更多，因为这是一项非常关键的技能。现在我们到了第30期，我们刚刚讲完了第15期，让我们在这里快速休息一下，我很快就会回来。谢谢。就在这本书里，它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。嗨，我是Max，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但肯定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是进入临床心理学博士课程。
to optimally prepare for presentations. It is incredibly important in psychology that you're able to do that. And it doesn't always mean like a PowerPoint jobby. You know, it could just be presenting in ward round or talking about some of your research or even presenting within supervision. So we've had 217 downloads of that so far, but we absolutely could do with some more because it's a really key skill now as we're at episode 30 and we've just covered episode 15 let's pause here for a quick break and i'll be back along very soon Thank you. Right here in this book, it's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, I'm Max, and I work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate.
带着这个最终目标，我想看看有什么资源，看看哪些书对这个目标有帮助。我偶然发现了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》，并决定这对我的旅程来说是一个很好的购买。我发现Marianne的书非常有信息量，而且最有洞察力。我特别喜欢这些故事如何让我确信，你不需要在学术上完美才能成为一名心理学家，只要你有良好的人际交往能力，比如同情心和共情能力，你就能达到目标。我强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家推荐这本书，也向那些想更多地了解临床心理学世界，也许有一天想在那个领域工作的人推荐。以及能帮助你获得资格的经验。所以来看看吧。
With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative and most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology, and maybe want to work in that field one day. and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look.
就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。欢迎回来。感谢收听。希望你喜欢片头曲。片头曲一直是这个播客体验中非常可爱的一部分。我喜欢片头曲。它们在你的脑海里吗？让我知道你最喜欢哪一个。所以第16期是与出色的Amy Brown合作的，她在斯旺西大学工作，是一位相当多产的研究员和图书出版商。我们思考了如何开始研究，以及父母心理健康和婴儿
It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. Thanks for listening. Hope you liked the jingle. The jingles have been such a lovely part of this podcasting experience. I love a jingle. Are they in your head? Let me know which is your favourite. So episode 16 was with the wonderful Amy Brown, who works at Swansea Uni as a fairly prolific researcher and book publisher as well. And we were thinking about getting started in research and also kind of parental mental health and infant
营养。如果你还没听过，你绝对应该听听，因为这非常有价值。关于父母心理健康和婴儿依恋的内容在心理学界非常关键。所以如果你有相关的工作背景，这将对你非常有帮助，特别是如果你还不是父母，或者不打算成为父母。哦，今天早上送孩子们上学压力很大。我在想，我迫不及待地想开始我的一天，因为你们让我抓狂。但很难不对孩子们说出来。但我们必须考虑我们言语的影响，如果他们在数学课上做白日梦，想到“我妈妈今天迫不及待地想把我送走”，那会是什么感觉。所以我没说，但我绝对想了。
nutrition and you absolutely should listen to this if you haven't already because it's really useful stuff and stuff on parental mental health and kind of infant bonding is so key in the world of psychology so if you've got kind of working background into that it's going to stand you in very good stead especially if you're not yet a parent or don't plan to become a parent oh this morning walking my kids to school was stressful i was thinking i can't wait to can't wait to get on with my day because you are driving me potty um but it's kind of tricky not to say that to the kids um but we have to think about the impact of our words and how it would feel if they were in a maths lesson daydreaming to think my mummy couldn't wait to drop me off today. So I didn't say it, but I definitely thought it.
是的。所以那是与Amy Brown合作的第16期。第17期是《作为有抱负的心理学家理解风险工作》。那只是我一个人在谈论我处理风险的经验，理解它，你知道，讨论它，为安全做计划，以及减少风险。到目前为止有258人收听了那期。第18期是与Graham Eorston教授合作的。我们思考了实际管理风险，你知道，设置房间的技能，以及与多学科团队（MDT）合作，真正成为一个有凝聚力的团队，以及团队中一个有用且被依赖的成员。到目前为止，那期节目有270次下载。如果你还没听过，请务必听听这些节目，因为我认为它们对你非常有用。第19期是与Steve Jones博士合作的，那是关于接纳与承诺
Yes. So that was that was episode 16 with Amy Brown. Episode 17 is understanding working with risk as an aspiring psychologist. And that was just little old me talking about my experiences of working with risk and understanding and, you know, talking it through and planning for safety and, you know, reducing risk as well. 258 people have listened to that one so far. And episode 18 was with Professor Graham Eorston. And we were thinking about practically managing risk, you know, skills to set up a room, and also working with the MDT as well, to really become a cohesive team and a useful and relied upon member of the team as well. We've had 270 downloads of that one so far. Please do take a listen to these episodes if you haven't because I think they're going to be super useful for you. Episode 19 was with Dr. Steve Jones and that was all about acceptance and commitment
疗法，以及它如何作为有抱负的心理学家帮助你。Steve Jones博士是《Act Made Yorkshire》的作者，所以如果你还没看过那本书，一定要去看看。第20期，我说过有多少人下载了吗？371次，我不记得我有没有说过了。嗯，第20期是与Ingram Wright博士合作的，和他交谈真是一种荣幸，我真的很开心，从他那里学到了东西。我真正喜欢他的一点是，他也真的很想了解我，这不仅仅是单向的。我真的觉得我是在和Ingram这样伟大的人在一起。所以一定要听听那期节目，到目前为止你们中有298人听过了。说到与伟大的人在一起，我在录制第21期时非常紧张，那是关于构思
therapy and how that might help you as an aspiring psychologist and Dr. Steve Jones is the author of Act Made Yorkshire so do check that book out as well if you haven't already. Episode 20, have I said how many people downloaded that? that 371 I can't remember if I did or not um episode 20 um was with Dr Ingram Wright and that was such a pleasure speaking with him I really had fun um learning from him what I really liked about him is that he's he really wanted to learn about me as well it wasn't just a one-way street and I really just I felt like I was in the presence of greatness with them with Ingram so do listen to that episode 298 of you have so far as well already speaking of being in the presence of greatness. I was so nervous when I recorded episode 21, which is the formulation
和权力威胁意义框架，与Lucy Johnston博士合作。我当时有一种“我不配，我不配，我不够好”的感觉。因为她在我的职业生涯中一直是一个灵感来源，也是一个巨大的帮助。所以通过Zoom见到她，并与她交谈，为你制作一期非常有用的播客节目，绝对是一种荣幸。你们中有574人下载并收听了那期节目，这并不奇怪。但如果你还没听过，也许标题让你望而却步，你知道，也许你会觉得“那听起来有点无聊，听起来有点枯燥，我真的对学习构思不太感兴趣”。实际上，对此我说
and the power threat meaning framework with Dr. Lucy Johnston. I just had a sense of I'm not worthy. I'm not worthy. I'm not good enough. Because she'd been such an inspiration and such a help for me in my own career as an aspiring psychologist so absolute pleasure to meet her via zoom and to you know to get get talking to her and you know produce a really useful podcast episode for you it's no surprise that 574 of you have downloaded and listened to that so far but if you haven't listened to it so far maybe the title puts you off you know maybe you're like that sounds a bit boring that sounds a bit dry i'm not really not really that interested in learning about formulation actually to that i say
你需要感兴趣。这是成为心理学家，特别是临床心理学家的一个关键部分。Lucy博士关于这方面的书也非常值得一读。在那期节目中，我们讨论了诊断是否总是有效的，以及它们是否实际上可能是有害的。所以请务必听听那一期。第22期是在我意识到我没有安排好节目，那天真的不想做心理学家时录制的。所以我认为那是有用的内容，所以它是《当你不在状态时如何做心理学家》。它引起了你们中一些人的共鸣，因为你们中有254人下载了它。但你知道，当你是一名谈话治疗师，或者当你与人工作时，这可能会很棘手，因为有时我们不想玩，有时我们只是想待在床上，不想和任何人玩，也不想和任何人说话。
you need to be it's a really key part of um of being a psychologist especially a clinical psychologist and Dr Lucy's books on this are really really worth a read as well and within that episode we talk about you know whether diagnoses are always useful and whether they can actually be harmful as well so please do listen to that one episode 22 was recorded when I realized that I hadn't got one scheduled and I couldn't really be bothered didn't really feel like being a psychologist that day and so I thought that was useful content and so it's how to be a psychologist when you're not in the mood um and it resonated with some of you because 254 of you have downloaded that but you know could be tricky when you're a talking therapist or when you work with people because sometimes we don't want to play sometimes we just want to stay in our bed and not play with anyone and not talk to anybody.
这是作为人类的一部分。但除非请很多很多病假，否则总会有一些日子你必须在不在状态时去工作。所以一定要听听那一期。下一期让我有点难过。你知道，第23期到目前为止只有177次收听。它是关于如果你爱的人是有抱负的心理学家，如何支持他们，或者如果你是有抱负的心理学家，如何向周围的人寻求支持。是的，主题还在继续，你知道，那些能滋养你的内容是收听率最低的。我认为这些正是你度过这段旅程最需要的。所以，请务必收听，回到开头再听一遍，随着这个播客系列的发展去听，
And that is part of being human. But short of having many, many sick days, there are going to be days when you're going to have to go into work when you're not in the mood. So do take a listen to that. This next one makes me a bit sad. You know, episode 23 has only had 177 listens so far. And it's about supporting someone you love if they're an aspiring psychologist or asking for support from people around you if you're the aspiring psychologist. And yeah, the theme continues, you know, the stuff that will nourish you is the least listened to. And I think that's the stuff that you most need to get through this journey. So, you know, please do listen, you know, go back to the beginning listen again go through this podcast series as it builds you know
与它一起成长。嗯，把那些片头曲记在脑子里，真正地，你知道，贯穿我所有节目的是同情心。我希望你热爱你所做的事情，但在过程中也要爱你自己。它并不总是需要自我批评和刻薄。所以请务必听听那些对你来说似乎不那么吸引人的节目，因为它们都非常重要，内容也非常有用。所以是的，让我们增加第23期的下载量，让你支持自己，并寻求更优化的支持。所以第24期是关于权力失衡以及当我们作为医疗专业人员时，我们帮助的客户之间的受托关系。那是一个特别请求的节目，到目前为止有176次下载。
grow with it um you know get those jingles in your head and really you know what runs through all of my episodes is compassion i want you to love what you're doing but to love yourself in the process as well it doesn't always need to be self-criticism and meanness you know so please do listen to the ones that might not seem so appealing to you because it's all so important and such useful content. So yeah, let's increase the downloads of episode 23 and get you supporting yourself and asking for more optimal support as well. So episode 24 was about power imbalances and the fiduciary relationship between the clients we help when we are healthcare professionals. That was a special request episode that's had 176 downloads so far.
我知道这听起来不是一个很时髦的标题，对吧？但我真的想不出该叫它什么。所以，如果你对重新编辑这些播客节目的标题有什么建议，请告诉我，因为我知道强有力的播客节目标题可以决定成败。这可能决定了人们是想听还是错过。但无论你在哪个心理学分支工作，在任何助人行业，这都是非常重要的内容。第25期是关于培训期间为人父母，那是与Rose博士（虽然她现在还不是博士，但她会是的）合作的，她目前是一名三年级实习生。她强调了许多关于当你作为心理学家，特别是在培训期间为人父母时，非常有趣和有用的观点，以及你如何能够优化支持你同届或
I appreciate it's not a very jazzy sounding title, is it? But I couldn't really think what to call it. So yeah, if you've got any suggestions for re-editing the titles of these podcast episodes, let me know, because I know that strong podcast episode titles can be make or break. It can be whether people want to listen or give them a miss. But it's really important stuff for whatever branch of psychology you're working in and in any helping profession as well 25 was about being a parent during training and that was with not dr rose but she will be dr rose um who is a third year trainee currently um and she highlighted so many interesting and useful points about when you are a parent yourself as a psychologist, especially during training, but also how you can optimally support any parents in your cohort or
未来同届中的任何父母，这在成为一个非常好的同届成员、朋友、同事方面是非常重要的考虑因素。所以即使你不想成为父母，或者你还不是父母，也要听听那一期。第26期是我被要求录制的，关于在心理学职业生涯中是否总是需要硕士学位，那是与纽曼大学的Mel West博士合作的，到目前为止有197次下载。第27期是《如果你感到失望，如何应对下一个申请周期》。这非常重要，我们需要在经历挫折和打击后能够重新振作起来。到目前为止有217次下载。我们最新的节目之一是《NHS：培训前、中、后的工作》，在发布后的一周多时间里，已经有169次下载。上周的节目是关于
future cohort, which is really important stuff to consider in terms of, you know, being a really good cohort member, friend, colleague. So have a listen listen to that even if you don't want to become a parent yourself or if you're not a parent yet episode 26 was what i've been asked to record about whether a master's is always needed to progress your career in psychology and that was with Dr Mel West of Newman University and that's had 197 downloads so far. Episode 27 was how to approach the next application cycle if you're feeling disappointed. It's really important and we need to be able to pick ourselves up again after we've had setbacks and knockbacks that's had 217 episodes so far one of our newest episodes was the NHS working within it pre during and post training that's had 169 downloads so far in just over a week since it was downloaded. Last week's episode was on
教育心理学，与出色的Michelle McDowell博士合作，在过去七天里有149次下载。即使你不想成为教育心理学家，听听这期节目也非常有趣和有用，因为它为你提供了关于在学校工作以及了解教育环境中发生的各种事情的有用且有趣的信息。今天，我在周一和你交谈。如你所知，新的播客节目在英国时间周一早上6点发布。那期与Deborah Kingston博士的节目，第30期，截至此时此刻，我刚刚刷新了一下，有41次下载。所以几个小时内，我们有了41次下载。这绝对会在全天和整个一周内继续增长。但第30期，哦，这真是一种荣幸，我们讨论了这么多事情。我们讨论了作为一名阅读障碍者在
educational psychology with the wonderful Dr. Michelle McDowell and that's had 149 downloads within the last seven days. It's really interesting and useful to listen to even if you don't want to become an educational psychologist yourself because it gives you useful and interesting information about working within schools and getting to know the different bits and pieces that happen within the education setting. And today, I speak to you on a Monday. As you know, new podcast episodes drop in on Mondays at 6am UK time. And that episode with Dr. Deborah Kingston, episode 30, has of this very minute, I just refreshed, had 41 downloads. So within a couple of hours, we've got 41 downloads. And that will absolutely continue to build throughout the day and throughout the week. But episode 30, oh, it it's such a pleasure we discussed so many things we discussed what it's like um you know being dyslexic within the
心理学世界中是什么感觉，以及晚年被诊断出患有阅读障碍，Deborah就是这样。从军队退役，然后重新培训成为一名心理学家。论文在论文不顺利需要重写时的动摇。这些内容非常有用、有趣，而且充满了同情心。还有关于在法医服务部门工作并做出富有同情心的改变的内容。这真是让人起鸡皮疙瘩。确实如此。这就是我们到目前为止30期节目的快速回顾。你可以通过访问我的网站goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast轻松补听。今天我实际上在那个页面上安装了一个非常棒的播客播放器，所以过去我一直在努力记住手动上传每一期节目，但今天我设法弄清楚了如何做
world of psychology and being diagnosed late with dyslexia um which deborah was um retraining um from um being in the military to then becoming a psychologist um A thesis wobbles when the thesis didn't work out and needed to be reset. Such useful, interesting stuff and with such compassion as well. And there's also stuff around working in forensic services and making a compassionate difference. It's just spine tingling stuff. It really was. So that is our little whip through of the 30 episodes so far um you can easily catch up on them by going to my website goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and today I actually um installed a very whizzy podcast player on that episode so in the past I've been trying to remember to upload each episode manually but today I've managed to work out how to do the
播客播放器，这样所有的节目都会自动加载在那里，你可以从那里获取它们，或者你可以通过Spotify、Amazon Music、Google、Apple Podcasts访问它们。你知道，如果我不说，我就失职了，如果你在Apple Podcasts上收听，如果你确实喜欢这些内容，你能花点时间给这个播客系列评分和评论吗？这不会花你一分钟。你所要做的就是找到这个节目。我将和你实时一起做。所以如果你去你的播客应用程序底部，点击“资料库”，然后点击“节目”。向下滚动直到看到我的，因为你应该订阅。
podcast player so that all of the episodes will automatically load there so that you can grab them there or you can access them via Spotify or Amazon Music, Google, Apple Podcasts and you know I'd be remiss if I didn't say if you're listening on Apple Podcasts please if you do enjoy the content could you just take a moment to rate and review the podcast series? It will not take you a minute. All you do is find the show. I'm going to do it with you in real time. So if you go to the bottom of your podcast app, click library and then click shows. Scroll down till you see mine because you should be subscribing.
你绝对应该订阅。点击那个绿色的，《心理学家播客》，然后在右上角有一个小圆点菜单，如果你点击它，那应该会加载节目。如果你向下滚动、滚动、滚动、滚动、滚动、滚动到……所以目前在第23期下面写着“预告片”，如果你在预告片下面向下滚动，它会写着“评分和评论”。所以如果你能直接点击五颗星，那将非常棒。那会很棒。但如果你有额外几分钟，如果你向下滚动，点击“撰写评论”，你可以留下评论，让其他人知道为什么你认为这是一个值得收听的好节目，那将产生巨大的影响。在我们谈论
You definitely should. Click on the green one, the psychologist podcast and then in the top right corner there's like a little um dot menu and if you um so that should load the show and if you scroll down down down down down down down to um so at the moment just underneath episode 23 it says trailer if you scroll down below trailer it will say ratings and reviews um so if you could just literally click on the five stars would be amazing um that would be great um but yeah if you have an extra couple of minutes if you just scroll below click write a review and you can leave a review to let other people know why you think it's a good thing to listen to it would make such a difference and whilst we're talking about um subscribing please do go and um
订阅的同时，请务必去订阅我的YouTube频道，在那里你也可以看到播客嘉宾的视频。那是“Good Thinking Psychological Services”。当我此刻和你交谈时，我们有209个订阅者和212个视频。所以，来订阅这个频道吧，因为上面也会发生其他好事。所以感谢收听这期节目。
subscribe to my youtube channel which is where you can also see the videos of the guests on the podcast as well. And that is Good Thinking Psychological Services. And as I speak to you right now, we've had 209 subscribers and 212 videos. So yeah, come along and subscribe to the channel because other good stuff happens on there as well. So thank you for listening to this episode.
我认为这是一个帮助突出你可能错过的任何内容的好方法。希望你觉得它有用。如果你有任何特别想听的节目请求，或者甚至是你希望我采访的人，或者也许你想向我推销自己，以便在《有抱负的心理学家》播客上接受采访，那么请告诉我。通过访问我的网站goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast与我联系。在顶部，有一个关于如何联系或如何请求你可能喜欢的特定节目的选项。所以是的，做所有那些好事，你就会成为我的新好朋友。我们可以预订一个
I thought it'd be a really nice way of helping highlight any content that you might have missed. So hope you find it useful. If you've got any special requests for episodes that you'd really like to listen to, or even people that you'd like me to interview, or maybe you'd like to pitch yourself to me to be interviewed on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, then let me know. Get in contact by going to my website, goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And at the top there, there's an option for how to get in contact or for how to request specific episodes that you might like. So yeah, do all all those good things you'd be my new best friend um we can book ourselves an
下午茶，那会很棒。但是的，回顾这过去的六个月真的很愉快，你成为我世界的一部分。我知道我经常谈论这个，但我从不认为这是理所当然的。我很高兴你在这里，我也很高兴你信任我来帮助发展、引导、塑造和培养你。所以再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我将期待着……我本来想做一个Peter Kay的梗，但我认为我做不出来。是的，就像Chorley FM。我不打算做。我无法让自己说出那些话。但如果你知道，如果你看过那个，你就会明白我的意思。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着与你再次交流。
afternoon tea somewhere that'd be marvelous um but yeah it's been really nice um recapping these last six months with you and you know you being part of my world I know I speak about that a lot but I do not take it for granted. I am thrilled that you're here and I'm thrilled that you trust me to help develop, guide, shape and nurture you. So thank you once again for being part of my world. And I will look forward to, I was going to do a Peter Kay thing then, but I didn't think I could carry it off. Yeah, like Chorley FM. I'm not going to do it. I can't bring myself to say the words. But if you know, if you've watched that, you'll know what I mean. Thank you for being part of my world. I'll look forward to catching up with you
在某个地方喝下午茶那真是太棒了，嗯，不过确实，和你一起回顾这过去的六个月真的很愉快，你知道你成为我世界的一部分，我知道我经常提到这一点，但我从不认为这是理所当然的。我很高兴你在这里，也很高兴你信任我，让我来帮助你发展、引导、塑造和培养你。所以再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我很期待，我本来想模仿一下彼得·凯，但我没觉得我能演好。是的，就像Chorley FM那样。我不打算做了。我无法让自己说出那些话。但如果你知道，如果你看过那个节目，你就会明白我的意思。谢谢你成为我世界的一部分。我很期待与你再次交流。
from 6am next Monday, when you can download the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which I will level with you. I am just about to record now. And then I'm going to do lunch with Marianne for my people in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And then I'm actually going to have some lunch myself. I think I'll have some hummus and some rice cakes and some brie and some salad and maybe even some port saloo as well because port saloo rules um maybe a bit of ham um like a nice little polish kind of coleslaw thing which i'm'm slightly addicted to. Tomatoes, a bit of lettuce. Yeah, that's what I'm going to do. So yeah, I hope that's made you hungry. If it's breakfast time, it might not have done. It might be like, oh dear, too early for thinking about hummus.
从下周一早上6点开始，届时您可以下载《有抱负的心理学家》播客的下一集，我跟您交个底，我马上就要去录制了。之后我要和玛丽安一起为《有抱负的心理学家》会员群组的人共进午餐。然后我自己也要吃点午饭。我想我会吃点鹰嘴豆泥、米饼、布里干酪、沙拉，也许还会来点波特萨卢奶酪，因为波特萨卢奶酪太棒了，嗯，可能再加点火腿，还有那种我有点上瘾的波兰风味凉拌卷心菜。西红柿，一点生菜。是的，这就是我打算吃的。所以，希望这让你感到饿了。如果现在是早餐时间，可能还没让你饿，你可能会觉得，哦天哪，现在想鹰嘴豆泥太早了。
But yeah, that's my slightly oversharing about my lunch. I think I'm hungry. I think I'm hungry. On that note note take care of yourself i'll catch up with you very soon with dr marianne jernan my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologistologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
不过，这就是我关于午餐的过度分享。我想我饿了，我想我饿了。说到这里，请照顾好自己，我很快会和玛丽安·杰南博士一起回来。我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我觉得关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there, and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通往那里的途径之多让我感到惊讶，成为一名临床心理学家并没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。